do to convince you to get here nothing
he never invites me actually I invited
myself I always invite you what the [__]
is that
Mark's got a stiff neck if you haven't
noticed I go you want to jump on JK news
I'm usually busy or doing something I'm
okay bye I just feel like I don't
believe Bart that much what the [__] how
come you don't believe me because you
seem tense it's not my neck this time
it's like my my [__] rhomboid or some
[__] wrong boy listen raw boy what
happened again to your neck or you're
sorry Robert oh is this [__] I was
just I was just working out this morning
it's like oh what feels good I got a
good warm-up in and then literally like
oh
the guy next to him goes oh happy
birthday